لطالما ارتبط مصطلح التعنيف بالمراه لكن
الاحصائيات في العراق تخالف هذا التصور
السائد لدى زينب المشاط القصه
[موسيقى]
لتدور الحكايات اليوم عن شهرزاد والساطور
بعد ان سجلت وزاره الداخليه العراقيه
حوالي 233 حاله عنف ضد الرجال لهذا العام
في السابقين كان تعنيف الرجل طرفه
يتداولها العراقيون فيما بينهم اما اليوم
فاصبح حقيقه مضحكه مبكيه لدى الكثيرين
منهم وعلى الرغم من تصاعدي حالات العنف ضد
الرجال الا انهم يصرون على التعامل مع
الامر على انه نكته فالمجتمع هنا اعتاد ان
يكون الرجل هو المعنف للضحيه اما بالنسبه
للنساء فجدنا ان العنف الذي تسببنا به ما
هو الا رد فعل لافعال كثيره وقعت عليهم
بين عامين 2014 و 2020 سجل العراق اكثر من
ثلاثه الاف حاله عنف ضد الرجال اختلفت
اسبابها واغلب هذه الحالات ان لم تكن
جميعها وقعت بفعل زوجاتهم وتنوع العنف بين
اللفظ والجسدي و بعضه ادى لقتل الرجل او
انتحاره
تزداد حالات العنف ضد الرجال في اقليم
كردستان العراق فهنالك مراكز خاصه لواء
رجال المعنفين وترى الناشطات في مجال حقوق
المراه ان هنالك اسباب متعدده تدفع نساء
للعنف منها الفقره وتضيق المجتمع على
المراه فضلا عن ظاهره تعدد الزوجات كل هذه
الاسباب تدفع لانتشار هذه الظاهره زينب
المشهد صباح العربيه بغداد
هذا الخطا انا الصور انهم التربيه احنا
عاده نحترم والدنيا نحترم ما اخونا وايضا
احترم الزوج ما يصير انه يتجاوز على الرجل
المفروض نحترمه سبب تعنيف المراه للرجل هو
يعني تغير او اختلاف نوعيه الرجال
المراه تتجاوز على الرجل هذا ليس من
اخلاقنا كالمجتمع شرقي اسلامي
العراقي السبب اليوم الرجل ضعف الشخصيه
اختار امراه اقوى من عندها بالشخصيه
لطيفه مشاعر راقيه تصنع الحياه وخلقنا من
انفسكم ازواجا فالربما لي ظروف نفسيه او
لضغوط حياتيه او لربما اسريه كلها يدفعها
بهذا التنمر وهذا فعل
من بغداد ينضم لينا البحث الاجتماعي احمد
الذهبي سيد احمد يعني نسمع اليوم عن ارقام
صادمه لحاله تعنيف ضد الرجال بعض بدنا
سابقا ان الرجل هو الذي يعنف ما سبب
ارتفاع هذه الظاهره في العراق
صباح الخير صباحكم مبارك صباح السعاده
صباح الاناناس لاجمل ناس ونهنئ
الشعب العربي الشقيق السعودي بالفوز
الباهر ونهنا انفسنا لذلك نقول صباح
السعاده صباح النفوس الامنه المطمئنه
صباحكم عسل
نعم
زياد حالات التعنيف او العنف ما هو العنف
ما هو العدوان العنف هو سلوك عدواني هدفه
تهميش الاخر لذلك ارتفعت معدلات العنف في
المجتمعات العربيه وما نلاحظه في العراق
بان ارتفاع معدلات العنفذ وذلك لارتفاع
السلوك العدواني نلاحظ بان الحياه او
وتيره الحياه اصبح ايقاع الحياه متغير
لذلك نمط الحياه اصبحت الاضطرابات النفسيه
منتشره بشكل كبير واسع جدا لذلك عندما
نقول اصبح المجتمع بحاجه الى مصحه نفسيه
هو ليس مثلك اليوم الكل مصابون
بالاضطرابات النفسيه وكما يقول فرويد كلنا
عصابيون ولكن بدرجات مختلفه لذلك يجب
علينا ان نراجع انفسنا لذلك نعم نعم
هذا الكلام ولكن عندما نسمع ان المراه
تعنف الرجل انت كباحث اجتماعي هل هذا
الوضع وهذه الحاله تضع الرجل في خانه
الرجل اصلا وتضع المراه بكل انه يفتها
ونعومتها في خانه المراه ايضا
خانت الرقي وعن وعن خانه الانوثه هناك
مقوله اذا اردت ان تعرف رقيه امه
نعم نعم نعم نعم انا اتواصل معك في الحديث
هذا كله ما هي اسبابه هناك هناك في
المجتمع الزياد السلوك العدواني الزياده
لذلك اصبح المجتمع اليوم بحاجه الى الطب
النفسيه بحاجه الى المختص النفسي بحاجه
الى الاستشاره النفسيه ولكن حقيقه نحن
كمجتمعات عربيه كمجتمعات شرقيه نعتبر
عندما نعم هناك اضطرابات نفسيه الكثير من
النساء بحاجه الى المختص في علم النفس
بحاجه الى الى الطب النفسي نعم هناك شذوذ
هناك تشوه خلقي واخلاقي وتشوه نفسي وتشوه
في القيم وكذلك نحن اا تمزقت مظلات القيم
والاخلاق وعندما انا احب ان اوجه كلامي
واقول اذا اردت زوجه مثاليه فكن انت زوج
مثالي وكذلك اقول من الملام في الخلافات
نحن في الطب النفسي نقول من بالخلافات
انتم تقولون ولا ربما الكثير من الناس
يقولون المسبب او المسيء لا الملام هو
الاعقل والاحكام في اداره في اداره
الحوارات في اداره هذه العائله الامنه
المطمئنه
نعم
من هو الاحكم من من ما تفسيرك للاحكام من
هو
الاعقل داخل هذه الاسره داخل هذه المملكه
السعيده ان كانت هذه المراه هي الحكيمه هي
العاقله هي الرشيده يجب ان تدير وان تسقي
الاسره بالحب وان تسقي العائله لذلك نحن
لم نجد هناك العقل او العاقل او الاحكام
سواء كان امراه او رجل نعم هناك الى ربما
تدمير او نسف لمعايير الاسره ولمعايير
الحب والسعاده والعيش والام نحن اصبحنا
صحراء قاحله جافه هذه الصحراء اصبحت تتعطش
الى كلمات الحب الى كلمات الاحتواء
الابتسامه في وجه الغريب صدقه ولكن
الازواج يحتاجون الى الاحضان يحتاجون الى
القبلات ولكن مع الاسف اصبحنا في سلوك
سلوك عدواني سلوك جارح نتنمر على الاخر
واسبابها
يا استاذ احمد الذهبي
شكرا جارحه
كلام جميل لكن انتهى وقت البرنامج تماما
شكرا لك سيد احمد